que jean-pierre colombiès porte parole
de l'association de police union des
policiers parce que nous sommes
indépendants
bonsoir jean pierre colombiès merci
d'être avec nous alors votre collègue de
vigie vous l'avez entendu parle
carrément de mensonges vous vous l'avez
trouvé comment l'audition de christophe
castaner globalement est globalement il
a fait la démonstration que lorsqu'on
écrit un discours on est toujours
meilleur que lorsqu'on se lance dans une
improvisation aléatoire et à risque ça
c'est un fait
ensuite je oui effectivement je devrais
pas rentrer dans une sorte de bâche in
castaner ou de castetner bashing pour
autant on peut pas on ne peut pas nier
que on se demande de quelle police il
parle lorsqu'on entend parler de paix
est ce plus qui est qui qui est destiné
à retourner vers les quartiers qui est
en fait une sorte de copier-coller avec
une nouvelle adaptation une nouvelle
dénomination de ce que fut la police de
proximité
on sait bien que sur le terrain ça ne
marche pas ça ne fonctionne pas tout
simplement parce que ça n'existe pas et
la réalité dijonnaise nous nous rappelle
à quel point le chemin est encore très
long à parcourir pour qu'une présence
policière crédible et légitime puisse
retourner dans les quartiers donc on a
eu droit effectivement des déclarations
d'intention des déclarations d'amour de
c'est effectivement de quelque chose qui
a été écrit et réfléchi en amont c'est
évident et j'ai envie de dire
heureusement pour autant il faudrait des
heures pour revenir sur tous les points
qui a évoqué lui dise de l'intérieur
mais à l'évidence ne compte n'y est pas
une peut pas y être tout simplement
parce que ça part comme il le dit et là
pour le coup il faut lui rendre cette
justice sa part de très loin des
gouvernements qui ont précédé celui ci
n'ont pas pris en compte le malaise et
les difficultés profondes qui règne au
sein de cette constitution gouvernements
précédents d'ailleurs je devrais
peut-être a dit que quelqu'un lui
rappelle un certain que emmanuel macron
faisait partie je rappelle qu'il était
quand même secrétaire générale sous la
présidence hollande est également
ministre du budget et comme l'a rappelé
monsieur castetner c'est tout part
souvent justement des arbitrages qui
sont effectués à bercy donc rendons à
césar ce qui est à césar et si
aujourd'hui on ne peut constater que je
dirais globalement des échecs multiples
à tous les niveaux
vous du maintien de l'ordre au niveau de
l'implantation dans les secteurs au
niveau des méthodologies et bien c'est
un petit peu parce que des hommes au
pouvoir aujourd'hui n'ont pas tiré les
conséquences il de leçons du pouvoir
passer donc pour 5
il y avait un point évidemment très
attendu cette fameuse clé d'étranglement
d'étranglement selon un ministre de
l'intérieur est bien cette technique ne
sera plus enseignée elle sera encore
utilisé mais plus enseigner une réaction
oui oui parce que je vous savez ce débat
est très compliqué parce qu'on parle
d'événements qui ont provoqué la mort
d'un individu la mort de personne dom et
c'est toujours compliqué lorsqu'il ya
une forte charge émotionnelle de revenir
sur un débat est sur une technicité
comme ça là bon maintenant soyons
sérieux deux secondes deux secondes
il y a dans ce pays des dizaines de
milliers de contrôle et d'interpellation
dans ce pays combien sont-elles le dé
générer de façon aussi gravissimes très
peu et heureusement d'ailleurs
et c'est très bien maintenant je vais
vous dire une chose lorsque vous
intervenez dans un climat d'hypertension
de dangerosité immédiate que vous devez
faire face à un individu qui est
potentiellement extrêmement dangereux
pour lui-même comme pour autrui je vous
mets au défi de mettre en pratique
quelques techniques d'interpellation que
ce soit qu'ils ne soient sans danger
c'est impossible tout simplement
impossible alors aujourd'hui on fait le
procès d'une technique on va les
substituer une autre et je peux vous
assurer que peut-être dans 5 ans 10 ans
ou l'année prochaine une nouvelle
polémique naîtra du fait de cette
nouvelle technique parce que tout
simplement il n'y a pas de technique
parfaite chaque cas est particulier
et lorsque vous êtes face à une hyper
violence face à des individus qui sont
de véritables bêtes sauvages dans
certains cas vous n'avez pas d'autre
choix que d'utiliser tous les moyens à
votre disposition pour le maîtriser
donc c'est un débat qui est malheureux
qui triste parce que ça part comme je
voulais dit du décès d'un individu ça
c'est pas normal on est bien d'accord
mais combien garde non vraiment bien
garde à ne pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain
parce que là pour le coup c'est tout
l'équilibré de ce qui fait le vivre
ensemble que nous mettons en péril jeter
l'opprobre sur l'institution police en
règle générale ou sur la gendarmerie je
rappelle quand même que là-bas traoré
est mort dans une gendarmerie et non pas
dans un commissariat
c'est prendre le risque mais avéré que
demain nous soyons dans une société où
la police et la justice seront tétanisé
pour exercer leur mise
on est où les conflits intra
communautaires et communautariste vont
exploser on l'a bien vu à dijon mais
dijon dé dijon vous savez il y en a
partout en france
et si on n'y prend pas garde si vraiment
besta garde si vraiment renonce à ce que
le pouvoir régalien existe vraiment en
plus profond des quartiers eh bien ces
exemples pour se multiplier se
démultiplier je peux vous assurer qu'à
un moment donné ou à un autre il y aura
des morts il ya eu une annonce un celles
concernant les caméras piétons
accélération en clair du déploiement de
ses nouvelles générations de caméras
piétons c'est l'une des solutions pour
vous c'est une des solutions dès lors
qu'elles sont exploitables et dès lors
qu'elles sont utilisées de façon honnête
et pragmatique ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que il ne faut pas qu'elle soit
perçue comme un autre à contrôler ou un
contrôle de plus de l'action policière
qui a en elle même est déjà très
contrôlé il faut aussi qu'elle soit en
capacité d'être utilisés contre les
personnes qui sont contrôlés car dans
certains cas dans de très nombreux cas
dans de trop nombreux cas les policiers
sont confrontés à des individus qui
n'hésite pas qui n'hésite jamais à les
insulter à leur manquer de respect à les
provoquer justement pour parfois en
arriver à des situations explosives et
d'ultra violence donc et ça je le
regrette aussi le ministre n'a pas eu un
mot sur la cohérence judiciaire dans ce
pays qui manque rarement de sérieux on a
l'impression qu'ils à véritable
amateurisme dans dans la vision que ont
repris par rapport à la cohérence
judiciaire et ça c'est dommage nous
assurer qu'il faudrait des heures pour
remettre tout ça à plat pour en discuter
de manière je dirais constructive mais
on ne peut pas traiter un problème sans
remédier à un autre c'est vrai
véritablement un enchevêtrement de
problématiques complexes face au calme
serein face à quoi nous sommes
confrontés
il faudrait vraiment prendre le temps
que des gens sérieux et non pas des
amateurs et non pas des gens qui ne
raisonnent que par moscow gants que par
des effets d'annoncé s'assoient autour
d'une table et travaille vraiment
vraiment sur des sujets concrets
merci beaucoup jean pierre à colombiès
de nous avoir accordé cette interview en
direct sur rt france